generally speaking scaling to body
weight seems to do fine in the
longitudinal trials where that's how
they dose protein
but i think when you look at
the mechanistic reasons that larger
people probably ought to need more
protein and then you look at the
practical considerations i think in when
you really dig into it it seems most
intuitive to me to scale recommendations
to fat free mass and ultimately that's
that's why we do it that way in macro
factor so
it's a good question and you'll probably
notice that i i don't just like give a
very specific clear answer and say
here's the exact study that shows it and
it's because you really have to piece it
together here and focus on
piecing together research that is you
know there's some longitudinal studies
there are some
kind of mechanistic theoretical
considerations to keep in mind there are
practical considerations to keep in mind
but a study that simply
as far as i'm aware has not been done is
the one where they say
this is a longitudinal study where we
show conclusively that scaling to body
weight is better than a flat
recommendation across the board and also
scaling to fat free mass is even better
than scaling to total body weight yeah
it would take quite a study to do that
like it would be quite an undertaking
but um yeah that that that is my
perspective on the question at hand yeah
i'm uh
i would say i'm very sympathetic to the
perspective that
uh maybe scaling to total body mass
isn't the best way to do it um largely
just from coming from the training side
of things where for
[Music]
decades when you were talking about like
uh
uh quantifying training dose like volume
load was
the only thing used or like the thing
al almost exclusively used um where it's
just like yeah we're gonna do sets times
weight times load and and that's what
we're gonna use to normalize things and
uh
seems to work in the literature so
that's what we're gonna go with um but
then you look at the literature and it's
like well
this is this is the only thing you use
like you haven't tested alternatives and
then what what really broke the
floodgates open was when people started
doing more low load training research
where you know you're normalizing the
number of sets people are performing but
total volume load is much higher with
low load training but you're still
getting pretty similar hypertrophy
responses
and that kind of got people thinking
like eh maybe maybe sets is both simpler
and
better like it seems to be more
predictive of hypertrophy than total
volume load is um
as you mentioned there there hasn't been
an ideal study in the nutrition world to
see if a similar dynamic could be in
play with protein um and so i'm
sympathetic to
the argument that it might be um but
yeah we we would just need
uh some some pretty audacious studies to
uh to to really dig into that
yeah and and it's possible that maybe
there's something even better than
you know even if we assume that
scaling to body weight is better than a
flat dose and we assume that scaling to
fat free mass is better than scaling to
total body weight even if we assume all
that to be true it's possible that there
could be something even better
than that because
i would expect that
muscle and non-muscle fat-free tissues
have a different impact on protein needs
you know um the other
on one hand you're thinking about the
actual turnover of skeletal muscle
proteins and how if you know if you grow
bigger and bigger with more hypertrophy
maybe that factors into it you also have
to think about uh splanchnic extraction
like extraction of gut tissues that are
you know taking some of that protein for
their own use before it you know makes
it out
and ultimately makes it to skeletal
muscle tissues um you know there's a lot
to be considered there uh so it's very
possible that
even scaling to fat free mass as if it's
just a singular thing could be uh you
know an oversimplification so you could
get down into details as granular as you
wish in terms of kind of
theorizing and mechanistic speculation
but for me uh i think that
recommendations currently do pretty well
if you're using total body weight over
kind of the
the middle portion of the
range of body body fat percentage values
and but the the nice thing about fat
free mass recommendations uh you know
scaling to fat free mass is that you can
generalize and extrapolate that even
into the extremes of uh
very far below average body fat levels
and very far above average body fat
levels so for my use
that comes in handy for me personally